the first teaser trailer from Netflix's
chilling Adventures of Sabrina is here
and it is well chilling it's safe to say
this isn't the Sabrina Spellman of the
Melissa Joan Hart era it's uh give me a
sec to get ready of it gotta go but fans
will see some familiar characters like
Sabrina's love interest Harvey who is
played by Ross Lynch ET sat down with
the actor who dished on how he landed
the role alongside Kiernan Shipka I
never went in for a chemistry read
that's my first read with Kiernan they
were like apparently they had been
looking for this Harvey character for a
long time and then they were like oh
cool yeah we like Ross and I was like
okay cool
went in again for a like Warner Brothers
live test which means there's no cameras
it's just like a bunch of executives in
a room and you like walk in you do the
season then you leave it and then I got
a call the next day and said your
flights tonight had you watched the
Melissa Joan Hart series at all now have
you still have it only I want to know
you want to bring your shows really
different is it darker very much though
and when et caught up with Kiernan she
dished on how this remake differs from
the og series were you a fan of the
original I was a fan of the original I'm
also big fan of the comics and the most
recent comics that came out is what the
show is sort of gonna be most similar to
and it's a bit darker it's very dark and
edgy and she's fun and
spoken to Melissa Joan Hart if you asked
her for any advice or if you guys tried
it we've only tweeted we have only
tweeted but I hope to meet her she seems
lovely we have to ask her if you met her
I'm always very interested asking people
sort of about their take on their take
on the character and sort of thought she
has about Sabrina because I anything
would be super inspiring to hear I'm
sure et was with Melissa and her former
castmates in 2017 and they said they'd
be down to do a revival of their own we
would do it in a heartbeat if we can I
mean as her family if we could go back
to the set tomorrow I would do it we
would go back tomorrow absolutely and
they aren't exactly ruling out a guest
appearance on the Netflix series should
they come calling and they want you guys
to guest star join that show would you
be down yeah I mean it depends like Who
am I gonna play I don't know
Never Say Never but I'm not expecting it
[Music]
[Applause]